wir sind heute an der suntrust seiner
high school in ciney valley in
kalifornien
kathrin hat uns eingeladen in ihren
unterricht und wir erklären euch heute
wie man setze mit je desto bildet los
geht's je länger wir im kreis laufen
desto spindelegger werden wir je mehr
leute janosch beim gitarre spielen zu
hören desto glücklicher wird er je mehr
sie trainieren desto stärker werden sie
die konstruktion je desto benutzt man
immer mit komparativen adjektiven das
heißt man vergleicht zwei dinge je
lauter desto besser je mehr geld desto
besser
man kann sie nur mit adjektiven oder
nomen bilden diese sätze aber auch mit
ganzen sätzen
je mehr geld ich habe desto
unglücklicher bin ich der je satz ist
immer der nebensatz und der desto satz
ist der hauptsatz je mehr mineralwasser
schauen trinkt desto besser wird er
je mehr deutschen schlager wir hören
desto wilder tanzen wir je lauter die
klasse ist desto ungeduldiger mit die
lehrerin
hallo
[Musik]
je mehr lena übt desto besser wird ihr
spagat
je öfter neuer sich schminkt desto
schneller wird sie beim schminken
je besser janisch witz ist desto mehr
lacht die klasse und der hase sagt
plumps je schneller andrew rennt desto
eher ist er beim mittagessen
je mehr big bang theory tobi guckt desto
schlauer wird er die laut soll ich
singen
je lauter desto besser je länger wir in
der sonne sitzen desto schlimmer wird
unser sonnenbrand je schneller weg ist
desto schlechter wird ihm das du
emotional wird von apple
[Musik]
je mehr stofftiere wir haben desto
weniger gestresst sind wir bei unserem
test
jedes tor ist die standard konstruktion
die man überall lernt man kann jedoch
auch sagen je
umso lauter ich bin umso mehr leute
hören mich und in der umgangssprache
hört man auch ganz oft umso am
satzanfang umso lauter ich bin desto
mehr leute hören mich je mehr ich
nachdenke desto weniger weiß ich je
länger wir auf dem hügel rollen desto
dreckiger werden wir je mehr easy german
videos desto besser je höher wir
springen desto besser wird das foto 123
wenn ihr selbst aktiv deutsch lernen
möchte dann solltet ihr unbedingt unsere
app ceiling ausprobieren
dort findet ihr interaktive videos zum
deutsch lernen zum beispiel zu diesem
thema aber auch zu vielen anderen
ihr könnt dort euro vokabeln trainieren
regelmäßig euch an eure eigenen vokabeln
erinnern lassen und auch eure aussprache
üben probiert das mal aus wir freuen uns
wenn ihr die seite ausprobiert sieling
dort kommt und wir freuen uns auch wenn
wir uns nächste woche wiedersehen tschüs
und bis bald
[Applaus]
das war mein erster konzert in meinem
leben